My new oncologist wants to use targeted hormones for my bilateral ER positive invasive ductile breast cancer and give me lupron.
A food method, a ribocycleib, to shrink by two weeks and give me more surgical options, still double mastectomy, maybe less radical reconstruction.
He said that the drugs would be temporary. What are the risks? Well, again, I'm not a pharmacologist. I'm not an MD. I can't call it on the risk of those drugs.
But I do highly suggest you Google them. Just Google them. You can see the risks of these drugs. You can see the side effects of these drugs.
You're going to have to do your own work on I literally I don't I'm not that's not my specialty.
So, and I legally can't make too many comments on that. But you it's all over the internet. You could easily Google each one of those drugs. See what the negative side effects are and look at the risk reward.
Just like I did with my cancer, I just looked at the risk reward, interesting with my cancer, a study had, you know, when I found out I had cancer about two years prior to when I found out so about seven years ago, male had just finished a study. I think on 10 patients that had had that had my cancer.
And they did this drug and it was a repurposed old chemo therapy. I can't remember the name of it. And they what they they call this that their trial is huge success because one one person lived like 16 months.
And I thought, okay, one person lived 16 months on top of that. You read the report read the entire report, which was very long. One that one person lived 16 months. He went into remission with the chemotherapy. And then his cancer came back and I think 14 months.
He refused further chemotherapy, which again told me, okay, that means, okay, the chemotherapy sent him into remission. Why would he refuse it if it came back except that it probably caused so many side effects for him. He was like, it was a guy is probably like, forget it. I do that again. I'd rather die. Okay, well, it told me a lot. The guy went into remission with it and he refused it. That was their success story.
Okay, easy, easy decision for me. Like what are those capital one commercials, easiest decision of the decision making decisions.
Well, I'm not going down that road. So, but again, I was willing to get you know, again, I come from a perspective of, okay, I gave myself to Jesus Christ. I have to go, okay, Lord, if you want, but if you want me to still do this, Lord, because you have a purpose in this cancer that's way beyond me getting better, then I'm willing, you know, I'm willing to do the chemo if it's you need you need to witness to some chemo nurse or something like that.
But please, you know, my heart, I do not want to do it, even if it had good stats, you're going to change my heart. But I trust that God could change my heart. He's big enough to be able to change my heart. If I, you know, open to listening to him. Well, he didn't give me any inclination that I wanted to do the chemo. And so it just was just a done deal with me. I was just done. And so it was either I was going to, you know, figure out myself by God, give me me wisdom to.
Help my body heal or I was going to go home and I was okay with either outcome. So it's, you know, so far, I'm still here. So I'll just go, hey, day by day, I don't know if the cancer is going to come back and I'm going to be dead in a month or I will get run over by a dump truck tomorrow. So you just continue to live your life daily like you're going to get run over by a dump truck tomorrow.
So that you, you are in a deep enough self analysis to that you can be asking God what you're supposed to be doing today.
What are your thoughts about this combo? Again, I cannot comment on a couple of medications.
These are questions I just, I don't have experience on I just can't comment on them.
I don't want to do you people a disservice. I don't want you to you guys to think that I know everything about, you know, these medications and their interaction. I mean, you can look up each medication. You can see the side effects of it, but you just need to be hard pressed and find any information on interactions between these medications.
So you're going to have to have a relationship with your heavenly father that you can ask him and ask him to give you wisdom, whether you should do these things, should I do a double mass activation, I do reconstruction.
Nobody can answer that question. The truth is we've had breast cancer patients come to us. They were like, forget it. I've done with them. I'm not doing any more standards of care.
And they are still alive today, but we've also had breast cancer patients that took that stance. I've done with them, but they they've passed away, but they were at peace about their physician.
Then we've had breast cancer patients that went the whole medical route and that passed away and we had breast cancer patients that went the whole medical route also and they're still with us. So you can't take a dogmatic position.
And I think any doctor that's going to say, you do what I do. This is what this is what you have to do. This is what's going to save your life.
It's like, really? Okay. Yeah, because honestly, if things go south, what's that doctor going to do? Oh, we do the best, we do the best. You know, it's like they're not taking responsibility for this. This responsibility has to fall on your shoulders.
You have to decide what's going to be best for you. That's just the honest truth.
So he said the drugs would be temporary and what are the risks? I don't know. What are your thoughts of the combo?
Should you still be doing some natural aromatase inhibitors? Yes, I would say like that question we had earlier, even if you're going to go with a medical route, I would still be doing natural aromatase inhibitors along with it.
He said, I'm an imminent danger of the large four centimeter tumor breaking the skin. And I'm worried about this. No one.
To help me with this locally, I especially do not want to have an emergency surgery decision. I agree. And you don't you won't don't want to be in a situation that you're making an emergency decision.
And you know, a lot of people aren't comfortable with the tumor breaking through the skin. And I get that and that's where doing some other intervention can be beneficial.
You know, I tell everybody that's thinking about doing chemotherapy and it's scared to death of it, but they feel like they're being kind of led in that direction is that the truth is, you can start. Doesn't mean you have to, you know, if they say, oh, we're going to do 12 weeks of this, then 12 weeks of this.
I think I could do it all. You're in control of your body. You could, you could stop if this I have done, you know, you might change your mind. I've had people, we're going to start this. I really feel like to do chemotherapy. They do two rounds and they're like, I'm stopping. That's it. And it knocked it down. So just remember that too.
He said my ultrasound showing the tumors near the same size since September doesn't matter.
Interesting logic there. It is opinion. The alternative program isn't working.
I would, I think it's kind of funny, you know, some of the dogmatic positions of the doctors.
If you were doing his program and there was the same side since September, he'd say, good, we put a break, the breaks on it, which would probably be true. And it's just kind of funny.
So good thing. What I would recommend if you're getting these kind of silly dogmatic nonsensical answers like this is to get maybe another oncologist's advice too.
You go to four or five six oncologists, you know, and have somebody that you feel the most comfortable with ultimately that's what you want to do. You want to feel really comfortable with it.
I want to give the oncologist another plan or compromise that we can work together and want to be comfortable and I don't want to make an uninformed decision totally agree with you and there's nothing wrong with talking to more doctors.